60 angular degrees is about 1 radian.
That's easy to remember once you get used to it.
But remember, it's ABOUT 1 radian.
It's not precisely 1 radian.
360° is 2π. 2π is 6.28 something.
60° is a 6th part of it, a 6th part of 6-point something is 1.
And now we can work backwards.
If 1 radian is 60°, then 0.1 radian should be 6°.
And this requires the use of a calculator, I guess.
The ratio of this leg to the hypotenuse is the sine of 40°,
so what we are needing is the ratio of this leg
to this hypotenuse is the sine of 40°.
The number that we are looking for would fulfill the following:
that number divided by 10 is the sine of 40°,
which means multiply both sides by 10.
We need the sine of 40° multiplied by 10, which is about 6.4.